the simpsons has been around for a very
long time
and while every episode brings with it
new jokes some gags have been recurring
again and again for years from odd
geography to embarrassing photos
here are the best long-running jokes on
the simpsons
the simpsons is a satirical comedy which
means that to strike as broadly as
possible
it has to be set in the most average
seeming place imaginable
so writers came up with springfield a
mediocre town that's also full of
goofballs and weirdos
so as not to impose any regional
characteristics on the midsize city
and keep it as down the middle and
relatable as possible
the state where springfield sits has
aggressively never been revealed
all viewers really know is that its
capital city
is literally named capital city and that
the governor is named mary bailey
diligent simpsons fans have looked for
contextual clues for years
trying to pinpoint springfield's exact
location but they'll likely never find
it
it's physically and geographically
impossible for springfield to be a real
place
information about its locale is
purposefully contradictory
and it's one of the show's best
prolonged gags in the behind the music
parody episode behind the laughter
springfield's location as given as both
northern kentucky
and southern missouri in the simpsons
movie ned flanders
says the town is nestled between such
far-flung states as ohio
maine and nevada in many episodes of the
simpsons
homer mindlessly watches television and
comes across an infomercial
invariably hosted by aging washed up
b-movie actor troy mcclure
but claire usually introduces himself by
saying i'm troy mcclure
you probably remember me from such films
as the revenge of abe lincoln
and the wackiest covered wagon in the
west he then lists a couple of terrible
sounding old movies from his apparently
vast resume of forgotten projects
among his dozens of credits we've got
the boat jacking of supership 79 dial m
for murderousness
here comes the coast guard they came to
burgle carnegie hall
and gladys the groovy mule troy voiced
by
big voiced saturday night live cast
member phil hartman
got a lot of hosting work in the
simpsons universe as he also
introduced hotel information videos
telethons and tv specials
while listing his corresponding past
credits his work in educational films is
particularly hilarious
with titles such as earwigs ew lead
paint delicious but deadly
and 2-3 equals negative fun the running
gag comes full circle when the simpson
family actually meets troy mcclure
and mentions the films they remember him
from homer simpson is a man of simple
pleasures
but all the beer donuts and bad tv are
offset by a strange fixation on goals he
never has the drive to achieve
marge you're standing in the way of my
boyhood dream of managing a beautiful
country singer
the result homer has earnestly stated
several times that a given
aspiration is his boyhood or lifelong
dream
among those goals there's his desire to
manage a country music singer
to be a monorail conductor own the
dallas cowboys
be an inventor like thomas edison live
in the woods and get rid of bart
whenever homer brings up another
steadfast dream marge
almost always points out that he
recently fulfilled his dream
like eating the world's biggest hoagie
running out on the field during a
baseball game
or appearing on the televised talent
contest the gong show playing a huge
harmonica with barney
while both were inside a giant pair of
overalls
in recent seasons herman hermann
proprietor of hermann's military
antiques
hasn't appeared all that often on the
simpsons in the early days of the
simpsons however
hermann was a predominant side character
a springfield townie
on par with the likes of kent brockman
or helen lovejoy and similar to those
characters and their handful of defining
traits
hermann had his whole thing too herman
knows a lot about military history and
strategy
and he's also rather paranoid physically
it's quite noticeable that herman is
completely missing his right arm
viewers might presume he lost it in a
long ago combat skirmish
that's not necessarily the case riders
made a dark and ghoulish running joke
out of just how
herman became separated from his
appendage in the 1990 episode
bart the general herman claims that he
stuck it out of the window of a moving
bus
and a passing truck tore it off years
later in the episode to cur with love
it's shown that herman lost it while
trying to hail a ride and it was ripped
off by chief wiggum driving an
animal control vehicle as it was in real
life there was a hotline for everything
on the simpsons in the 90s
and just like in the real world the
hotlines in the series would have such
high call volumes that they put callers
on hold and make them wait for a while
allowing time to pass with some soft
rock hold music
the simpsons mock this phenomenon by
making the weight music as savagely
funny and on the nose as possible
for example when homer feels
disconnected from bart he calls the
national fatherhood institute for help
and while on hold they play harry
chapin's gut-wrenching absentee dads on
cats in the cradle
in another episode when marge leaves
baby maggie in homer's care
she runs away and so homer phones a
missing child hotline
and quickly tears up when the whole
music is players baby come back
characters on the simpsons coin a lot of
words and one of the best is
retiring a clever construction from the
usually less than sharp chief wiggum
that can be used to identify an
especially durable running joke from the
simpsons itself
it's combination of retire and irony and
wiggum tells a financial planner in the
2000 episode
homer vs dignity that he doesn't have a
plan for the future
because retirement will ensure he's shot
and killed three days before he leaves
the police force
but what if you don't get shot what a
terrible thing to say
the simpsons first use of the retiree
concept is a direct
jab at action movie cliches in the 1991
episode homer watches a mcbain movie in
which the title character's just about
retired partner is brutally shot by a
hitman
all while the poor guy is holding a
photo of his new boat
the live forever retiree was
subsequently taken to
absurd places homer smashes a news
camera hidden in a hat
which had one day left until retirement
while searching for homer a police dog
one day from retirement smells the man's
underpants and runs away
and then marge accidentally frees a
group of prison inmates who chief wiggum
notes were quote
one day away from being completely
rehabilitated
the triangular flags known as penance
seem like an old-fashioned form of
showing fandom
since mr burns was seen holding a beat
harvard pennant after attending a game
in the 1996 episode
burns baby burns but the pennant gag is
also a reliable staple for homer simpson
for years homer seemed to always have at
the ready a professionally made pennant
for every occasion no matter how minor
inappropriate or private the experience
he had an xfl pennant to watch the
ill-fated football league's launch at
home on his couch
one reading mid-season to greet the
arrival of replacement television shows
a girth one to compliment his fat pride
t-shirt
and even one reading justice that he
held aloft from the sitting area of a
courtroom
initially conceived as a guy for homer
simpson to play against
lenny leonard was both a work friend and
drinking buddy to the main character of
the simpsons
a fellow mid-level employee of the
springfield nuclear power plant and a
frequent customer of moe's tavern
and over the decades that the simpsons
has been on tv lenny's character and
backstory has grown
deeper for example viewers learned that
he has serious
eye health issues and very bad luck
relating to those eye health issues
this all gave lenny one of the simpsons
grossest and funniest running gags
some unknown injury left lenny with a
fragile peeper
and yet it's frequently attacked by the
one ultra specific thing his doctor has
said to keep
out of there homer throws a dish of
pudding at lenny but he's
not supposed to get pudding in that eye
he's wrestled to the ground on top of a
jigsaw puzzle
even though he's not supposed to get
jigs in his eye other times
lenny and his poor eye are just in the
wrong place the wrong time
like when he takes off his eye patch for
the allotted five minutes a day and
fish guts get inside of him or then
there's the time that homer pranks him
with the old snakes in a can bit
sending a spring right into his cornea
the springfield nuclear power plant is a
big place and it's one of the town's
biggest employers
it's absolutely logical that the aloof
cynical and cruel man
who owns and runs the place c montgomery
burns
wouldn't be on a first name basis with
all of his underlings
but it's hard to believe that he
wouldn't remember homer simpson from one
day to the next
after all the safety inspector from
sector 7g
has worked at the springfield nuclear
power plant for many years
and they've often interacted off the
clock even in ways bordering on intimacy
or friendship
for example homer and burns were on the
same bowling team
homer acted as burns romantic wingman
and homer once served as
burns prank monkey this is to say
nothing of his attempts to woo marge
steal away grandpa simpson's girlfriend
or his enduring rivalry with grandpa
simpson himself
that's why the running gag of mr burns
completely forgetting homer simpson is
so funny
the character is so mean and
self-serving that he can't even find a
few brain cells to remember a man with
whom he's
shared multiple experiences whenever
homer comes up in conversation
mr burns has to ask smithers who he is
and this disregard is even held up as
homer's motive for trying to kill mr
burns
springfield's favorite bartender mo
sislak of moe's tavern
is a deeply unpleasant guy and hobart
simpson is one of his few friends
mo has spent a lot of time around
homer's family and has a particular
fondness for the simpson children
and yet he never seems to recognize bart
simpson's distinctive voice during one
of his numerous prank phone calls
to moe's place of business that only
makes the running joke of bart calling
up the bar even funnier
with the simpson boy asking to speak
with a patron whose name is an
obvious and slightly risque pun and mo
slowly realizing he's been made the fool
and flying into a rage is all over there
oh
oliver close off bart isn't much of a
student but he
really puts in the effort when coming up
with fake names for his prank calls
among the more memorable there's
alcoholic lee kibum
amanda huggin kiss and be a problem the
joke
really sails when mo reacts perfectly
asking the whole bar if the person with
that name
is there only to completely lose it when
he realizes that he said he has a
b.o problem springfield isn't all that
big a place and homer simpson does a lot
of dumb things
that creates the unique situation in
which he winds up featured on the
channel 6 news
with kent brockman reporting on his
latest boneheaded or accidental
shenanigans
in providing the audience with
background info on the subject of the
story
kent will pull up a file photo the
station already has on hand of homer
simpson
it changes with the episode and it can
only hilariously hint at just what
stupid activity homer was engaged in
when photo was snapped
there's at least a whole season's worth
of simpsons episodes that could tell the
stories behind these extraordinarily
damning and embarrassing pictures
such as an angry pantsless homer shaking
his fist to the zoo ape
homer with his tongue stuck to a pole
and homer apparently trying to set
some kind of world record with more than
a hundred cigarettes stuffed into his
gaping mouth
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one